vous dire est-ce que tu en as une petite
dernière fois deux trois monsieur c'est
un mec qui m'a présenté la rue il y a
une vieille dame toute vieille elle
attrape
ça va elle dit je vais vous lire la
bonne aventure il dit écoutez moi madame
je crois pas trop ce truc laisse-moi
faire
tu vas acheter une grande ferme dans
cette ferme il va y avoir plein de
vaches et chaque vache elle coûte 2000 €
et c'est vache là ils vont me faire
beaucoup de lait tu vas devenir
milliardaire
ça fait 150 euros tu commences à 150
euros j'ai pas d'argent moi a dit oui
mais c'est 150 euros je vous ai dit la
bonne aventure c'est pas grave prends
une vache
[Applaudissements]
avec moi pratiquement tous les soirs et
puis on attend son prochain spectacle
j'arrête les conneries à toi de
septembre 2023 on l'attend avec
impatience
merci mon Jean-Marie
et qui croit
j'en ai marre je crois que ma femme est
sourde
tu sais il y a un test à faire si tu
veux vraiment savoir si ta femme est
sourde tu rentres à la maison à peine ta
franchi la porte tu dis à autre
intelligible voix tu dis chérie
qu'est-ce qu'on mange toi si elle dit
rien tu vois dans l'endroit où se trouve
ta femme la cuisine par exemple une fois
dans la cuisine tu redis très clairement
chérie qu'est-ce qu'on mange si elle
répond toujours pas tu viens juste
derrière elle dans son dos mais tes
mains comme ça et tu dis chérie
qu'on mange et là si elle te répond pas
c'est qu'elle est sourde il va et ben je
vais essayer ce soir ouvre la porte
chérie qu'est-ce qu'on mange rien la
cuisine sa femme qu'elle a chérie
qu'est-ce qu'on mange rien va juste
derrière elle chérie qu'est-ce qu'on
mange et là ça va me se retourne a dit
pour la troisième fois des lasagnes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a 450 000 Français et 70 millions
de Juifs tunisiens
elle est avec mon meilleur chose la Go
en plus il est poto avec son âme alors
si jamais si jamais
ils apprennent
qu'il y a un bail chelou
ça va partir en couille bébé
[Applaudissements]
et tout d'un coup il voit un éléphant il
regarde
je te veux je te veux c'est un coup de
foudre je te veux je te veux je te veux
je veux te je veux te je
vais te c'est plus drôle quand on
emploie ce terme bien sûr
regarde-moi tout nous c'est pas c'est
impossible je m'en fous je m'en fous ça
coup de fou je veux te je vais te
au bout d'un moment c'est bon ben vas-y
le moineau
et au dessus il y a un chimpanzé qui est
là allongé sur une branche entrain de
manger une noix de coco et il fait je
rêve c'est dingue qui est en train de se
passer je vois un moineau qui nique un
éléphant j'ai jamais vu ça
le chimpanzé que il lâche la noix de
coco elle tombe sur la tête de
l'éléphant l'éléphant effet aïe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ils sont en déplacement et à un moment
donné pour dormir reste plus qu'il
chambre ils sont mariés chacun de son
côté tu vois écoute c'est pas grave on
est des adultes on peut dormir dans la
même chambre il y a pas de souci aimer
quand même ils ont une chambre avec deux
lits séparées donc ça va et en pleine
nuit le monsieur il se réveille
excusez-moi
vous pouvez me donner une couverture
parce que j'ai vraiment froid et là la
femme a fait elle lui dit écoutez c'est
ce qu'on va faire pour cette nuit on va
faire comme si on était marié tous les
deux
l'autre c'est chaud il dit ah ouais ça
serait super ça venez on fait comme si
on était marié il est d'accord ah bah
voilà chercher ta couverture connard
[Applaudissements]